every day doctors give kids drugs that
the US government hasn't approved for
use and children
it's called prescribing drugs off-label
it's perfectly legal
still it's a practice that concerns some
doctors as an individual I am infuriated
by this my colleagues in the business
are infuriated by this and there's not a
day that goes by that we don't that I
have to prescribe a drug that I know is
being given off-label so a drug that may
be absolutely safe and usable in a
two-year-old can in fact be quite
dangerous in a one-day-old
overall doctors say that when they give
kids drugs off-label sometimes the
results are unexpected take psychoactive
drugs I can remember an example of a
young boy maybe seven or eight who was
just disinhibited and literally jumped
out a second-floor window now scary
fortunately he didn't get hurt and it it
makes me a bit uncomfortable to talk
about these situations because you know
I was prescribing the medicine but we
you know we had have medicine where we
didn't have the data in kids about
proper dosing and we learned a bit by
trial and error that's why many doctors
think it's essential for the government
and pharmaceutical companies to study
drugs and kids of all ages the evidence
speaks for itself
you need to take the most dynamic
developing growing changing organism the
most vulnerable organism the child the
infant and the adolescent and you need
to study them if you're going to know
how to properly use these drugs
Diane Murphy is the government's point
person for testing drugs and kids over
the last decade her agency has been
working with Congress to require drug
companies to do pediatric trials the
agency was asked to put together back in
the late 1990s a list of products that
would benefit from being studied in
children the list in 2000 had well over
400 products we have now been able to
get studied over 220 using both the B
PCA and the prea you'd say gee
you're halfway there but you have to
also remember that every year anywhere
from twenty to thirty new products are
coming on the market so in the last ten
years we have about two hundred so you
see oh you're not making anybody that's
not true either because all those
products don't need to be studied in
kids so she says her best guess is
somewhere between 25 and 50 percent of
the drugs that need to be studied in
kids have been still she admits it's
been frustrating how could we end the
20th century and still not know how to
use properly the products that we're
medicines that we're giving children
well because it's really hard and
ethically you better make sure that
you're asking a good question and even
with a good scientific question studies
with children are just different among
the problems children can't give consent
that's like a fundamental basis of how
you do trials you have to have a whole
institution if you will or a group of
people who are child-friendly you have
to have nurses who know how to deal with
children you have to have an area that's
child friendly and not frightening and
then when you get past all of that you
still have to deal with do we have the
right kind of instruments do we have the
right kind of lab even with all these
problems researchers starts several
dozen pediatric trials each year but
trials can take years to finish in the
meantime how our doctor is supposed to
know how to use these drugs and children
first we can use pediatric dosing
guidelines that have been put together
by experts in Pediatrics second we can
go with our own experience prescribing
these medications or the experience of
our colleagues or third we can use adult
dosing guidelines and try to understand
from those guidelines what might be best
for use in children but even doctors who
are prescribing drugs off-label are
still grappling with whether they should
tell parents some doctors have to
absolutely an important part of the
informed consent process is being clear
with the youngster and
the family about what we know and what
we don't know and whether or not this
medicine is formally approved by the
Food and Drug Administration yes
we never discuss this issue with parents
interesting only enough that the fact
that the drug is used off-label is never
discussed with a family the interesting
part of that is is that you would have
to inform a patient if they were in a
research study involving the drug but in
terms of the everyday use of the drug
it's not required and I don't know
anybody who does it
but surveys suggest most parents do want
to know if doctors are prescribing drugs
off-label when we asked in our national
poll on children's health whose
responsibility is it to let someone know
to let a parent know whether as FDA
approval for use in children over 90% of
parents told us it's the doctors
responsibility one problem is sometimes
doctors don't know if they are
prescribing drugs off-label I don't
believe that most of the pediatric
community who prescribes medications
know what drugs are labeled and what
aren't labeled to help doctors the FDA
has set up a website that tells them
which drugs have been tested in children
pharmaceutical companies say they're
trying to find ways to get more drugs
tested faster and technology may help
speed things up too for example one
British company creates virtual clinical
trials in virtual children so modeling
and simulation esand virtual children
can provide guidance to the actual
design of those real studies but to work
the simulated child needs high quality
data from real studies obviously if
anything to do with computers if you put
garbage in you're gonna get garbage l
that data is being provided by
industries universities nonprofits and
regulatory agencies but they don't
expect virtual trials to be perfect
I think they'll always be the need of
you see for real experiments it's a
question of whether you can rationalize
the numbers of those and the need for
them in many cases are we doing too many
you know so in the first instance I
think this approach of modeling and
simulation will inform us as to whether
a particular study is actually needed
and clearly if we can show that the
outcome is not likely to be significant
then this will save a lot of time and
money but all these efforts could get
caught in legal limbo that's because the
US law that requires pediatric trials
runs out in 20
12 I think these laws need to be
finalized so we don't have to go back
and ask Congress every five years to say
kids are important would you please
renew these laws many experts say it's
unlikely that Congress will let the laws
lapse but they say the uncertainty is
hard on everyone it takes a village to
raise a child I think we're all
responsible in some ways we as
physicians and clinicians need to be
advocates we need to push for more good
research data so that we know that the
drugs were prescribing work and that
they're safe and he's as parents
Congress the FDA and National Institutes
of Health all play important roles too
and finally the pharmaceutical industry
they make the medicines they market them
and they have the resources to do the
kinds of studies that can give us the
information we need of course there's a
lot of competition for those resources
companies can't just test all drugs they
need to develop new ones too and that's
why Congress has created financial
incentives for the pharmaceutical
industry to test those drugs companies
can get a longer patent on a drug if
they test the drug and children the
question is are those incentives enough
to speed up the process Congress will
take another look in 2012
you
Sciences published by triple-a s the
science society